World War two saw lots of heroes Winston
Churchill shall de Gaulle commander
Eisenhower
but one you probably don't recognize is
smokey a Yorkshire Terrier and the
tiniest war hero of all time
I feel smokey and I were destined to be
together that's bill when a corporal at
the time and Smokies owner he bought
smokey for six dollars and 44 cents
during his time serving in the Pacific
Theater I think that if she fallen in
anyone else's hands she would never have
been what she was and she was remarkable
smokey followed a Bentley through 150
air raids twelve combat missions and
once even led bill to safety during a
Japanese bombing kaboom kaboom kaboom
well we look around we got eight of our
buddies all wounded Brown we're smokey
and I were if smokey hadn't taken me
there I would have been standing with
the other guys
smokey also accompanied nurses on their
rounds at a US Army Hospital in New
Guinea smokey gets credit for being the
first therapy dog on record back in
Bill's hometown of Cleveland smokey
became famous doing tricks on TV shows
she could walk down a drum she could
ride a scooter
smokey died a celebrity in 1957 but she
wasn't forgotten she has memorials in
Ohio Pennsylvania Australia Hawaii
Tennessee but her biggest legacy popular
belief is that Smokies the reason that
your keys are such apart
so thanks mochi the world war ii dong
for all those cute little Yogi's
[Music]